♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
Last night was Super Bowl LVII,
and out of habit,
Biden shot down
the Goodyear blimp.
The so called
"He gets us" campaign
ran two commercials
during the Super Bowl last night
to promote Jesus
and Christianity.
However, thanks to the referees,
Philadelphia no longer
believes in God.
During her halftime show
performance at last night's
Super Bowl, Rihanna revealed
that she was pregnant
while the rest of us
just ate like we were.
According to new analysis,
more than 50 million Americans
were expected to gamble
this year on the Super Bowl --
by serving Buffalo wings
and a one-bathroom apartment.
Elon Musk was photographed
last night at the Super Bowl
sitting next to Fox Chairman
Rupert Murdoch.
I think we have a photo.
There you go.
The State Department today
issued a do not travel advisory
for Russia.
Yeah, we weren't planning on it.
Bad news, kids.
I know you had your heart set
on going to the Kremlin,
but looks like
we're going to do Disney.
The State Department
said last week
that the downed
Chinese spy balloon
was carrying
surveillance equipment
capable of intercepting
communications.
They needed some way
on spying on people
who still haven't
downloaded TikTok.
The FBI announced on Friday
that it found an additional
classified document
at former vice president
Mike Pence's Indiana home.
Even weirder, they found it
in a file marked "Work stuff."
Oh, it actually -- it actually
is work stuff.
An owl was recently removed from
a college library in Georgia.
And this is annoying:
now it's saying "whom."
My two favorite things,
Shoemaker: owls and grammar.
Authorities in Texas
recently responded
to a report of two goats
on the loose in a Target store.
The goats were captured
and safely returned to TJ Maxx.
And finally, a woman in Chile
recently set
a Guinness World Record
after swimming about one and a
half miles in Antarctic waters;
said the woman,
"Can someone please rescue me?"
And once again,
we've miscalculated
what our closer was.
Today is Valentine's Day.
So if you're watching right now,
better luck next year.
According to the latest numbers,
the average American is expected
to spend $200 this year
on Valentine's Day --
or $400 of you made
her breakfast in bed.
Eggs are super expensive
right now, guys.
That's a joke about egg-flation.
That's what Bez' calls it.
In a video today announcing
she's running for president,
former U.N. ambassador
Nikki Haley said, quote,
"I don't put up with bullies
and when you kick back,
it hurts them more
if you're wearing heels."
Whoa, what job does
she think this is?
Does she want to be president
or teach Krav Maga?
"When I fight
for the middle class,
I'll hold my keys so they stick
out between my fingers."
She does make
an interesting point, though.
If she wins, she'd be the
first president to wear heels
since the last president.
A lawyer for President Trump
said recently that Trump
was using a manila folder marked
"Classified"
to block a small light
on a landline phone
next to his bed --
even weirder,
all the ones that he taped up
to use in place of curtains.
Buckingham Palace yesterday
announced that Queen Camilla
tested positive
for coronavirus.
Luckily, as a royal,
she was already planning
on doing nothing
for the next few weeks.
The maker of the robot
vacuum cleaner Roomba
announced yesterday
that the company would lay off
roughly 7% of its workforce.
And since it was Roomba,
it took everyone 45 minutes
to find the door.
Finally, according to
a new analysis by Yelp,
the most romantic restaurant
in Wisconsin
is Grandpa's Pizza.
That story again,
the only restaurant in Wisconsin
is Grandpa's Pizza.
The Pentagon this week described
the unidentified object
shot down over Canada
on Saturday
as a, quote,
small metallic balloon.
So it was either a dire
national security threat
or a wasted 25¢
at a county fair.
"Hold on to that, Tyler!
Oh, son of a gun."
President Biden
is reportedly considering
making a national
televised address
to discuss the recent
unidentified flying objects.
Oh, yeah, definitely,
please do that.
Interrupt an episode of
"The Voice"
and walk 30 yards down
that long red carpet
to a podium like Obama did
when we got bin Laden,
and tell the American people
you popped some balloons.
"Now, my fellow Americans,
it's true what they say:
once you pop,
you just can't stop."
President Biden announced
yesterday that Air India
will purchase more than
200 planes from Boeing,
while Frontier is buying
200 planes from Goodwill.
During the White House
press briefing yesterday,
a reporter from Newsmax asked
Press Secretary
Karine Jean-Pierre, quote,
Is President Biden woke?
And she rolled her eyes so hard
they didn't come back.
More haunting than I think
we planned.
President Biden said yesterday
that the back and forth
with Republicans in his
State of the Union address
made him feel like he was,
quote, back on the playground.
"So jealous,"
said Matt Gaetz.
Senator Ted Cruz
told reporters yesterday
that he plans to run
for a third term.
Cruz said he discussed it with
his family and they insisted.
The company Volt Candy has
issued a recall for its
PrimeZen Black 6000
male enhancement pill
because it contains
two unapproved drugs.
Yeah, something tells me
that people who bought
that don't keep their receipts.
I think they're going
to have to eat the $9.95.
And it doesn't matter
how I know how much it costs.
Two for $18.
The fast food chain Chipotle has
announced plans to open
a new brand called
Farmesa Fresh Eatery,
which will focus on
farm-to-table cuisine,
as opposed to their usual
table-to-restroom.
A Philadelphia Eagles fan
was arrested
on Sunday in Florida
after he allegedly
broke into a fire house,
peed on the carpet,
stole a hat
and threw a knife
at a firefighter --
and then he found out
the Eagles lost!
And finally, a Florida
city councilman
was arrested over the weekend
after authorities allegedly
found ten grams of cocaine
in his shoe.
Police first became suspicious
when someone in Florida
was wearing shoes.
President Biden had his annual
physical today at Walter Reed.
Doctors say
he's fit as a fiddle,
specifically, this 300 year old
Stradivarius.
That's right, President Biden
today had his annual physical.
And I think Fox News
messed with his eye chart.
Wouldn't count -- wouldn't be
legally binding.
According to a new report
top Democrats privately think
that President Biden is too old
for reelection,
but worry that his decision
not to run
would cause chaos
in the Democratic Party.
You guys didn't see this coming?
We elected a half-finished game
of Jenga
and now you all say, "Oh, no,
everybody move your drinks!"
President Biden
spoke publicly today
about the aerial objects
shot down by the military;
said Biden, "The American people
deserve to know
how much fun
this week has been for me."
Acting FAA administrator
Billy Nolan testified before
the Senate yesterday on the
agency's handling of recent
near collisions at airports
and assured Americans
that flying is safe.
I don't know, at this point,
the best you can say
is that it's safer
than traveling via balloon.
I would not want to travel
via balloon right now.
The FAA this week
announced plans
for an airline
industry safety summit
after a recent series
of near accidents.
But don't worry,
you only need to attend
if you're in the exit row.
Oh, boy. Oh, boy.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
A lawyer for Florida
Congressman Matt Gaetz
said yesterday that the
Justice Department informed
Gaetz that they will not
move forward with charges
relating to his sex
trafficking investigation
and that Gaetz
has learned his lesson.
"Venmo set to private"!
"The New York Times" published
an op ed yesterday
about Republican presidential
hopeful Nikki Haley,
titled "Nikki Haley Will Not Be
the Next President."
Yeah, I'm not falling
for that one anymore.
The last guy they said would
never be the next president,
turns out he was
the next president.
Also, still might be
Elon Musk said yesterday
that artificial intelligence
has great promise
and capability,
but added that it comes
with, quote, great danger.
So either he's one of the
great minds of our generation
or we finally saw
"The Terminator."
According to a new study,
Cleveland and Detroit
are the least expensive
U.S. cities for single people,
in the same way that the
cheapest car you can buy
is just to walk.
And finally, today was national
Do a Grouch a Favor Day.
Okay, off the top of my head,
let him crash with you?!
Hey, it's our friend who lives
in the garbage and eats trash!
Well, see you later.
That was a monologue,
everybody.
♪♪